innerhalb europas ist und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute
leute machen wir die logische
fortsetzung youtuber an den rücken haben
erkennen und youtuber am linken
ohrläppchen erkennen denn wir machen
heute youtuber an den felgen erkennen
das ist die nächste gesteigerte version
von youtube am auto erkennt wir haben
dafür einen experten der kamera andrea
wie heute der kamera der für uns die
felgen ausgesucht hat das ist eine
besondere schwierigkeit weil man jetzt
auch noch wissen muss zu welchem
automodell fähigen typischerweise hören
und youtube an das für den kulturen zu
ordnen also tricky kanada werde ich auf
jeden fall gedanken wie kommt mein name
ist bekannt für die reds der dienste
geben könnte es zeugt nicht von allen
guten geistern verlassen
max hat nicht so viel ahnung von autos
ich welchen ticken er deswegen müssen
wir schon auf macht sich im laufe des
wii ist nochmal stärken dazu holt zb
nein also ich wieder oben auf jeden fall
ein tor zu hoch heißt ein amg im
restaurant stehen in foren wird braucht
man dafür einen eher gebremst sehen auf
sind gelochte bremsscheiben okay also
wir haben im weißen eingeläutet
erweitern eigentlich immer die waffe war
die partie wartet im kabel oder nein
ein
[Musik]
offiziell hat richtig geschäft erlauben
wenn man ganz anderes auto schon
youtuber nennen also nicht möglich in
die oder befreite alaba lara may cry max
[Musik]
payne hat aber laut bekommen praxis vom
modell keine tv und youtube in
deutschland zur welt brachten
es war eine kurze runde hat auf jeden
fall noch fünf minuten gedauert würde
ich gern gemacht so weiter machen das
ist natürlich schöne auf 345 sowie die
klassischen wichtigkeit
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
von max von otmar knoll ein
hochauflösendes in den weg legen
das sieht auch nicht wie tat den winkel
lernen von autos
es ist mein haus sabi sabi sabi bin ich
vorbereitet
wenn auch abgeschwächt aus wörth
überhaupt nicht erkennen steht wegen
also ich glaube käfer der software ag
zum audi grau aus finde ich ein bisschen
auch wieder irgendwie erinnert ja ich
kenne das von ins cobra nicht nur dass
du gemerkt bei den gästen alles quatsch
erklärte
[Musik]
doch genau das war doch gerade für euch
ich kann nicht nur zum spielen lassen
wird jetzt mein auto den weg nicht aus
youtube kanal vorbei bringt sein erstes
leben auf youtube junge leute die gar
keine richtigen zahlen und da wird
keiner erwähnt ist ungerecht ist leute
ich habe komplett verkauft wenn ihr
mitleid mit dem ich hier um abonnieren
überkommt den verdienst wochen klar dass
wir hier geht's zur neuesten folge was
es geht macht der erste linke
beschreibung andré war okay leute das
war's